coverage from the white house there mark
good morning bill good morning to you
the white house admits what's going on
on the border
is a problem and even today we have seen
a number of high-profile officials start
to talk about what's going on
and it's interesting the homeland
security department put out a lengthy
statement
they said if the pace of migrants
crossing continues this will be the
highest number they've seen
in 20 years still the white house says
it's not their fault they're pointing
the finger at former president trump
saying his policies have left them with
unable to have the facilities and
resources they need
to handle what's going on we are
trying to work through what was a
dismantled and unprepared system
because of the the f the role of the
last administration
it's going to take some time but we are
very clear-eyed about what the problems
are and very focused on
putting forward solutions one of those
solutions having the federal emergency
management agency work on sheltering and
supporting unaccompanied minors
so far the white house not asking for
any more money to deal with this but
homeland security secretary alejandro
mayorkas
does have a message for migrants
considering crossing
now give us the time to rebuild the
system
that was entirely dismantled in the
prior administration
and we have in fact begun to rebuild
that system
the white house does want congress to
pass comprehensive immigration reform
but republicans say this is a crisis
created by this white house after
president biden's decision
to reverse so many of those trump-era
border policies
he can continue to deny it but the only
way to solve it is to first
admit what he has done and if he will
not reverse
action it's going to take correct
congressional action to do it
so far the white house has not announced
any plans for president biden to visit
the border but the president is going to
be going on the road starting today
be heading out to chester pennsylvania
that's right outside philly the plan to
talk
about the american rescue plan the
stimulus bill he signed into law
last week the focus being on what small
businesses can do to keep people on the
payroll but you can bet bill and dana
a lot of questions will still follow
them up to pennsylvania about what's
going on at the border we shall see
thank you mark meredith nice to see you
from the north lawn there